Yemen is in the midst of a civil war but
it really depends from which perspective
you're looking at it to say what war is
being fought. The outcome of the conflict
in Yemen has direct ramifications for
the future of the Middle East region
because of how it's played into the
sectarian dynamics in the region and the
actual power conflict between Saudi
Arabia and Iran that is taken root
inside of Yemen. There are now two
governments inside of Yemen both seen as
legitimate by their followers. What we're
looking at is a situation where Saudi
Arabia is backing a southern government
that's based in Aden and recognized by
the international community and Iran has
back the northern government in Sana'a
under the Aahuthi Sallah regime.
It creates an interesting dynamic where
should the country fracture into two, there
would be an Iranian mini-state and Saudi
southern border and a Saudi client in
the south of Yemen.  This is a significant
inflection from how Yemen used to be,
where the entire country used to be
under Saudi Arabia's influence and the
growing presence of Iran in the region
is a concern.
How do you think the war in Yemen
effects Middle East dynamics?
Let us know in the comments section and
let us know what other topics you want
AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.